yo yo yo what is up it's Jerry it's
Friday gotta get down on Friday and I am
here with another first impressions for
you yes you pat yourself on the back I
don't know why because you're you and
that's all that matters so uh late last
night Ryan and I went to a screening of
edge of tomorrow yes lived I repeat as
many folks seem to think the movie is
called because of the way the poster is
laid out so this is the new um Tom
Cruise sci-fi action flick and when I
first saw the trailer it kind of looked
like a greatest-hits medley of every Tom
Cruise sci-fi action flick we've seen
lately and I am proud to say that it is
not um this movie is pretty [ __ ]
awesome I gotta tell you I'm really
happy for for doug liman doug liman is a
director who probably most notably as a
recent to the bourne identity and the
bourne identity is a movie that at least
it seemed to me like people were like
that that's a cool movie i like that
movie and then for supremacy came out of
the bourne ultimatum came out never was
like oh my god these movies are
incredible paul greengrass yeah so you
know i always feel bad for for doug
liman because the other two more movies
sort of improve on that one and so
in relation to board so here he is again
with edge of tomorrow which is based on
a book with an amazing title which is
all you need is kill which is awesome
about that so this movie takes place in
the future and basically there's like a
mass alien invasion there's a war going
on and we're trying to fight them I mean
this is a sci-fi or been cooking away
this movie is really cool it's it's
really hard I think to get across what
the story is from the trailer we all
just kind of know that it's sort of
Groundhog Day with robotic exoskeleton
gun suit or something there are a lot of
surprises with this movie in a sense I
mean because you know you go in here not
quite sure what's going on unless you're
familiar with the book and that really
sort of helps make it a tree I mean
first off you've got Tom Cruise for the
first part of this movie really playing
against type in a way I mean it's not
like a really stretch of a performance
but you know they've got him as this
sort of cowardly guy and who gets thrown
into this combat scenario but it's cool
you know to watch his performance
because this movie does a really good
job at allowing its characters to grow
and change within the context of the
story and there's a lot to be
appreciated here the cast is really good
like I said Tom Cruise who ryan and i
have spoken about this many times it's
like everyone forgets they like Tom
Cruise until he makes another movie it
was luck miss Tom Cruise and then
another Tom Cruise movie comes out
people like but tonker is really kind of
this though like so this movie is no
exception there Emily Blunt is great in
this bill paxton's and I didn't realize
and he's always good Brendan Gleason's
in here um I I don't remember the actors
name but one of the guys from attack the
block is in this which I was really
happy about I think it might have been
the guy who played young den so yeah
this movie is really cool the designs
are really great um you know these sort
of exoskeletal suits and their alien
design is really cool the way they
and all that stuff is is different and
neat that way and this movie manages to
really balance out action and story
image in an interesting way because in
the first part of this movie and we were
on imax 3d by the way which which the
three anything imax are great in the
first half our first 25 minutes or so
gets to a point where it's almost over
where it is overwhelming where I was
becoming overwhelmed by the sheer amount
and grit of all the things crunching and
exploding and all the just the the
really tense battle sequences because
they really put you in the in the heat
of a battle which is why I sort of think
it's got you know a bit of a war movie
aesthetic in its blood the actions
really sort of intense and the movie
uses it's sort of reset the Day
Groundhog Day thing really beautifully
to ease and build tension and an ease
and build momentum in terms of action
and story and it allows for a very tight
pace it allows for action and it
justifies action and it doesn't sort of
get overly gratuitous I don't think in
either regard it's like there's not too
much talk and there's not too much
action there's a lot of action to the
point where it becomes overwhelming but
but when it does it's usually to serve
the point so I just think this is a
really well put together really balanced
in a well-balanced movie you know there
might be some things to argue about in
terms of plot mechanics just because
when you get any sort of complicated you
know sci-fi plot like this there's
always you know some to argue about but
um for the most part I think it's really
tight the effects are great I don't know
how expensive this movie was but it must
have been expensive it's well directed
it's really well shot props to tug
lineman from really pulling it out
nothing that I just sort of really found
cool about this was that on it's a very
international feeling movie a lot of it
takes place in London and France and in
Germany and it's it's not necessarily
one of those like adventure movies worth
like we have to go here and then you
know
an Indiana Jones aeroplane map trip you
know it's like a lot of the cast is
international and you know there aren't
an overabundance of Americans you know
just like square draw at American accent
guys so I thought that was cool the
music Christophe Beck score is great
there's a lot of interesting little
textures and tones in there that aren't
quite typical for this kind of movie so
I appreciated that so what we also has
just a lot of humor I mean the sort of
setup of this movie or the gimmick of
the story does allow for some very
natural humor too which really helps the
experience you know it really helps debt
to fleshed out and add a balance there's
also some you know more challenging
emotion for these characters that comes
from that um so that really helps the
humanity of the story just as much as it
does the the sci-fi in the action so
that's I thought that was really cool um
yeah i mean just definitely go check it
out you know whether it's in just a
regular screen or an imax or whatever
it's fun it's got a lot of humor in it
but it's also got you know weight and
intensity and this is i guess kind of my
kind of summer blockbuster because you
know it's fun it's got laughs but it's
also got some brains it's also got some
action so it's not only for popcorn and
soda but it you know it goes along with
that just as well and uh what do we talk
about today what's your what's uh what's
something that you really like Tom
Cruise in lately that you saw or
something like that you know um so yeah
till next time that's that's it for me
so its edge of tomorrow lift I repeat
cheers